I was new I was watching myself on on
the on the audition sequence and I
everything oh my god my voice was even
different but I remember that scene
where I had to run from my house across
the street to Trey's house to tell
Laurence Fishburne's character that
Ricky had been shot and I remember it
was a big wide scene and everyone was
involved and I was scared to death
because the scene started with me
and the first time I did it I think I
was fine I was okay but it wasn't as
hysterical as it needed to be and
Laurence Fishburne pulled me aside and
said come here I was like am I in
trouble did I suck he was Yoda and
that's it he was so he was the big
brother the father the expose after he
addresses thespian the you know he was
the theatre God and so he said to me
just be hysterical and for me I grew up
in that neighborhood so gunshots were
like normal to me I was like oh okay my
first actually remember the the actor
Floyd what was his name boy boy boy Ella
too is in the red car who actually shot
Ricky I went to elementary school with
him I'm not even kidding and he was a
straight-a student who ended up going to
prison and being murdered in prison yeah
so this this film is to me in my life so
when Laurence Fishburne said be
hysterical something clicked and I was
hysterical
but it was very important to me as a
young actor that this felt real because
I knew what it was like to run home from
school and hear gunshots at night doing
my homework
and meeting John and knowing that we
shared many moments of sort of growing
up and living in South Central LA it was
just
it was amazing so got the part cuz she
said when she read it she's like oh my
god this is my husband when I go at the
st. Mary's and the girls just want to
beat me up and chase me home I said okay
she's the girl hired